Gobbo mega-corporation nike which is
cooler and more virtuous than you has
made colin kaepernick the star of its
latest major ad campaign that's because
what real bravery looks like is getting
celebrated by almost everyone in power
and getting huge money from an enormous
enormous ly wealthy and influential
company many regular Americans aren't as
impressed though some have already
posted videos of themselves burning Nike
gear but before you throw your support
to another mega corporation who hates
your way of life consider this according
to reports Puma and Adidas also
proceeded Kapernick before he signed
with Nike so something much larger is
afoot what is it exactly Jason Whitlock
hosts speak for yourself on fs1 and he
joins us tonight
so Jason I read the story my first
thought was of you I'm gonna withhold
any more judgement and allow you to lay
out what this means I think that Nike
has issues PR issues they've been sued
for discrimination by both black people
and women they fired a bunch of
executives recently and long before any
of that Nikes had a problem with slave
labor slave labor in Asia and the people
that actually make their shoes Nike has
no problem with their oppression and so
I think that colin kaepernick aligning
with him is a marketing PR ploy by Nike
to cover up their larger bigger problems
and to feed the left-wing media so look
we're friends of Kaepernick so overlook
these years of criticism about the slave
labor that makes our shoes and the
exploitation that we're perfectly fine
with and then Chuck are I'll go even a
step further when you look at president
Trump's make America first policies and
how they're impacting couple
corporations like a Nike and the
business they do overseas go have their
materials made in another country for
less money and then bring them back into
our country without being taxed or
punished for that
I just think Nike is playing politics
here
on a number of different levels and it's
a PR stunt that I think is going to blow
up and backfire in their face no
different this reminds me of ESPN naming
Caitlyn Jenner the most courageous
person in America because she had a
sex-change operation I think this is cut
from that same cloth and how that doing
that a labeled ESPN is PC and out of
touch with middle America I think this
play here with Colin Kaepernick is gonna
backfire on Nike so what you're saying I
mean you're describing something a
little more sophisticated than just a
kind of reflexive kowtow to PC
Sensibility what you're saying is this
is a company that could be attacked on
legitimate grounds by critics and on the
left for exploiting workers for being
bad for the world but to avoid being
attacked they pay a kind of indulgence
attacks to the Church of PC by making
Colin Kaepernick even richer and they
don't get criticized is that what you're
saying
what without question and I think this
was really a hairbrained ideas game it's
a sign of desperation
iiiiii again I think it's going to blow
up in their face this is just bad
business and and and I get it for a
business to move into something this
polarizing with that sports fans it's
just crazy to me when Nike has made so
much money became this powerful force
going with Michael Jordan who avoided
politics and understand that everybody
at the end of the day buy shoes you know
the hypocrisy here by Nike is extreme
you know using Colin Kaepernick in this
way and I don't blame Colin Kaepernick
he's gonna take a check from wherever he
can get it this is Nike using him to
cover up for their own internal and
external problem but do you think
anybody that's such a smart point as a
business decision why would you if you
were Nike especially a company with
historically universal appeal want to
narrow your potential customer base
to 40% of the country or narrow it at
all why would you do that that seems
pretty short-sighted because there are
executives running all over America who
basically grew up in the countercultural
era of the 60s and 70s and now they're
in positions of power and they're doing
crazy harebrained things with their
companies again I've said it a million
times
ESPN eventually thought that doing PC
politics was good business and it's just
not there plain Nike and a lot of
corporations are playing to Twitter way
too often they think if we can just make
Twitter happy and make the left-wing
dominated Twitter happy we're gonna make
the world a better place and we're gonna
make our business better it's just not
gonna happen
it's so it's so smart it's a theme that
you hit it again again and again and I'm
glad that you do social media is
changing our world our society our
brains even in ways that we don't even
perceive thank you for reminding us that
Jason Whitlock as always